When do you think uh the general election is gonna be for sure
Lawrence will take over before the next year
I think the the best time will be July August period end of this year
end of this year a decade ago
you said if every Singaporean can feel
their life has become better than yesterday
then this government would have done its job well
but has the needle in your view
moved enough in the past decade
for it to translate into votes for the PPP
this election I don't think so
the needle will shift a lot towards a P
a P Heartlanders who have got a lot of support in this budget
so I think they can expect to get good support on the middle group
worry about the future and then elderly
very old I think they are also very happy the young
they want to look at who are the candidate
the personality personality a long time ago
you just need to have a PAP logo and can be anyone
he used to get 50% but in the last election
the Workers Party logo itself is capable of 40%
what is your advice to the leadership of the PAP
for the upcoming election?
They're trying their best with all the TikToks
that only is gonna address a small section
you really need to have a Singaporeans feel that
I understand your prom I cannot solve it today
but believe me I can solve it In the future.
I think we are losing ground on that portion,
and we have to regain that trust.
We can do that, and I think maybe we'll be okay.